hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast amino therapy a
revolution in cancer treatment
presented by Brad Nelson PhD
distinguished scientist and director
zealey research centre co-director
cancer immunotherapy program BC Cancer
Agency i am christina muhammad of
Lavery's and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by labrys lab Ruth is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational for
children and webinars before we begin I
like to remind everyone that this is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into that box
that appears on your screen we will
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you will be viewing
the presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
your presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this presentation is
educational and this offers continuing
education credits please click on the
button in the bottom left corner and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
now please join me in welcoming dr.
Nelson I will now turn the presentation
over to him
dr. Nelson well hello everyone and
thanks very much for the introduction
Christine we're here today to talk about
immunotherapy which genuinely is a
revolution in cancer treatment if you
haven't heard already it's really
changing the way cancer is treated in
the here-and-now
and it's going to have a major impact on
how cancer is treated in the future so
just to add a little bit more to my
introduction I work at the BC Cancer
Agency that's based in British Columbia
Canada our program I co-lead with Rob
Holtz who's at our Genome Sciences
Center and we're divided between two
cities Victoria and Vancouver and I'll
talk a little bit about what we're doing
although I'm going to keep this at a
pretty high level really talking more
about what's going on around the world
the immunotherapy in a nutshell is
illustrated in this cartoon what we're
trying to do is get immune cells
particular T cells to attack tumor cells
and so this cartoon illustrates it very
simply
we've got a t-cell on the left there
that purple-ish cell we only I'll tell
you a lot more about these but basically
these are a type of white blood cell
that we all have in our bloodstream
protects us from infections all day
every day but t-cells also have the
ability to recognize tumor cells and
just as shown here they can literally
attached themselves to the tumor cell
they can poke holes in it and inject
toxic enzymes and other compounds to
just cause the destruction of that tumor
cell within minutes of contact so the
you know therapy this is how we're
trying to fight cancer there are all
sorts of different what we call
modalities or approaches Tim you know
therapy this wheel I borrowed from a
review article that was published a few
years ago just really illustrating the
different approaches involving
antibodies vaccines viruses t-cell
infusions etc and through the course of
this presentation I'll touch on a few of
these different modalities but just want
to start by giving you the big picture
the immunotherapy is not one approach
but it's a whole suite of approaches all
of which have the same
which is to enhance the immune response
to cancer so the topics I will cover
today are first we'll just step back a
bit and talk about how does the immune
system respond to cancer in the first
place just what is the natural response
what does that look like before we even
try to intervene second I'll talk about
immunotherapy and really highlight well
why it is now the hottest field in
oncology and it's not just me saying
that by the way it's really generally
widely accepted now and you'll see the
breakthroughs that have been made this
really is where the big advances are
happening right now and I'll tell you
why and then of course what if the
future hold we've had some success now
but what do we see
looking forward from here what successes
and challenges lie ahead so starting at
really the beginning of our discussion
here let's just think about how cancer
develops and that will help really frame
the discussion about the immune response
and the you know therapy so starting on
the Left we have just some normal tissue
this could be your skin it could be the
lining if you're running your gut but
you've got a sort of normal cells and in
the second panel over we see something's
happen there's been some genetic damage
perhaps environmental perhaps other
reasons but a cell indicated in blue
there has become its DNA has become
damaged and mutated or changed in some
way and that can then lead to what we
call dysplasia which is these benign
lumps we all have a number of lumps and
bumps in our bodies that are benign just
plastic tissue
not to worry some on their own but those
if unchecked some of those can then
progress to cancer in the first stage of
cancer is what we call an insight you
Carson Oh
and this is um again earlier stage of
cancer we used the word insight you the
term because implies indicates the
cancer has not spread anywhere yet it's
still in the same situation or location
as it began when cancer becomes
challenging is when it becomes invasive
and starts to break out of its site of
origin and eventually start spreading to
neighboring tissues and unchecked it can
then start spreading around the body and
which we call metastasis and that's when
it's very challenging to treat so with
in situ carcinomas let's just step back
to that stage those are highly treatable
with today's treatments in general so a
surgeon can cut those lumps out you
might give a little bit of local
radiation to clean up any residual cells
but generally those are easily treated
it's when a cancer becomes invasive in
metastatic that it's very difficult to
treat because of course the surgeon can
cut out the tumors that they see but
they're unable to remove every tumor
from the body and so we have to come up
with what we call systemic therapies
treatments that are body-wide treat the
whole from head to toe on the assumption
that cancer cells can be hiding anywhere
and that's when we start using agents
such as chemotherapy to treat the whole
body and that's where immunotherapy as
we'll see plays a big role because the
immune system is everywhere and has the
potential to control cancer wherever it
might be hiding so just at a high level
or simple level what's happening as
cancer develops is in general that
there's an accumulation of mutations in
these tumors and as they progress and
those mutations are appear to occur more
or less randomly and then there's a
process of Darwinian selection
much the way species evolved on the
honor planet to those of all through
these random mutations but then tumor
cells are selected upon many tumor cells
die off they get mutations that are
actually harmful to them but once in a
blue moon you get just the light
constellation of mutations that rather
than causing that tumor cell to die they
actually give it these superpowers to
start growing out of control and
important forming these invasive cancers
so there's a real random element to all
of this which again makes cancer
challenging because no two cancer's are
exactly alike the next slide shows you
what what I mean by mutations and just
how corrupted or disrupted the cancer
genome can become so first of all the
term genome refers to the set of
chromosomes or genes in a cell on the
Left we're looking at a normal cell it
has the normal complement of 23
chromosomes they're nicely paired up
there and see two copies of chromosome 1
of chromosome 2 etc one copy comes from
your mom one from your dad at the time
of fertilization so that's what a
healthy cell looks like and on the right
I'm showing the chromosomes from a
typical cancer cell and what you see is
we've got something like five copies of
chromosome one shown there four copies
of chromosome two etc so you actually
have kidnap games in the number of
chromosomes
you can also have losses of chromosomes
or sections of chromosomes
you can also see there are some you get
my Quaker going here
here we see examples of a multicolored
chromosome that's a case where the
chromosomes have been cut apart and
pasted back together
in abnormal configurations so if you
imagine that this was a your laptop that
the software for your laptop undergoing
these kind of changes you might think
your laptop would crash as a result and
again probably these kind of mutations
do lead to cells crashing and dying most
of the time once in a blue moon you get
just the right combination of mutations
that actually leads to a highly viable
cell which starts to cause the problem
of cancer so again because it's a random
process underlying cancer the result is
that no two cancers are alike so I'm
showing you no chromosomal pictures from
six different cancers they're all breast
cancer and you can see just at a high
level that they all have in common the
fact that they are very messed up lots
of changes but the details of those
changes those aberrations are different
from case to case so when a patient
walks in a clinic with cancer and at
some level one could say their cancer
has never been seen before it'll be the
unique entity now it's not quite as bad
as that might sound in that especially
with modern genomic technologies we can
go much deeper than this and look at
mutations right down to the level of
individual letters in the genome and
then we can do sophisticated
computational analyses of these
bioinformatics and find that there are
patterns to all this the successful
cancer cells share common patterns of
mutations different pathways that are
being activated and so that provides
hope that there is some some sense to
all this and the therapeutic approaches
can be developed in a rational way
but nonetheless there's still as this
random element of the background that
presents a challenge to any type of
cancer treatment including an you know
therapy adding further to the complexity
cancers are not just as indicated here a
homogeneous entity it's not just at all
monoclonal homogeneous tumor cells but
rather because of the way cancers
evolved it's much like species on the
planet you end up with families of
cancer cells in a given patient they're
all related they all came from the same
grandfather or great-grandfather cell
and way back in time and they they've
acquired additional changes that make
them unique so on the I'm showing an
example from a patient with ovarian
cancer this is from a study of a
colleague of mine that was published
last year but showing here the different
tumor clones as we call them that are
found within this patient so the
patient's cancer started with something
that looked like clone a which then all
the time gave rise to a number of other
clones which are related but have unique
mutations within them as well and on the
right from the study what they did was
looked in the peritoneal cavity of this
patient where all there in cancer
resides and they sampled tumors from
different regions from the left ovary
the right ovary pelvic regions
metastatic sites etc and they using
genomic and bound formatic tools were
able to tell which of these clones from
the family were found at different sites
and so you can see for example in this
left pelvic region the tumor there was
composed primarily of clone B from this
family
where as we if we look down in the right
ovary the cancer that was found there
was composed of clothes G some E and a
little bit of H thrown in there so again
these cones are all related but but have
unique mutations and unique properties
so when we think about trying to treat
this patient again this is all data from
one patient we're really having to come
up with therapies that will treat and
kill all of these clones not just some
of them it would in theory just take one
clone that survived and the patient we'd
still be struggling with their cancer so
this is the enormous challenge that we
face when trying to treat cancer just
kind of recapping that I think a useful
analogy might be to think of using the
Mafia as an example here you don't just
have one bad guy in in a cancer patient
but you've got a whole family and
they're related and they probably even
work together to carry out their bad
deeds but there are some good guys in
this story as indicated by Charlie's
Angels here and this is of course I'm
going to talk about the immune system
and how it tries to fight back against
this corruption so the immune system is
basically all your white blood cells we
all have them they as I said earlier
they help fight infection all day but it
turns out the immune system can also
recognize cancer so I'm showing you now
an image ovarian cancer again this has
generated this picture in my lab from
one of our patient samples and what we
see is in purple first of all those are
all the tumor cells all the all the bad
guys that are forming the tumor in this
patient and in brown we see these so
called killer T cells
these are the cells I said talk to Luka
they're beginning that are able to go
and latch on to a tumor cell poke holes
in it
inject toxic compounds and kill it
that's why they're called killer T cells
we also have some helper cells in there
in green and some B cells in pink B
cells make antibodies and we think those
also help to fight the cancer so you can
see in this actual image live not live
but real image from a real patient you
can see her in the in system is actually
infiltrating the tumor much like foot
soldiers going into a battlefield and
engaging in hand-to-hand combat with
these tumor cells and fighting away so
in most patients we see this kind of
response to some extent I'll say a bit
more about that on the next slide
actually I'll just go to that I'm
showing you know similar types of images
but we're looking at three different
patients now just to show you the
diversity of response as we see when we
look at multiple patients so three
different tumor samples being analyzed
here and you can see on the left the
color code so here we're staining for
again the killer T cells are in sort of
a brownish color that help ourselves or
hopefully in this case and the B cells
are once again pink so you can see let's
start on the far right here that this
patient has a very strong immune
response we would say as indicated by
this battle that's going on in the
middle we have a patient with a moderate
immune response she wanted t-cells and
they they tend to be stuck in the
stromal regions of the tumor rather than
the actual malignant part of the tumor
and then this patient on the far left
has a very weak immune response in fact
her tumor looks in this case negative or
any sort of immune response
so I'll just make it clear we haven't
done anything to cause these patterns
the patient has patients have just
walked in off the street for their first
surgery they've just been diagnosed with
cancer and so this is a snapshot of what
their immune system is doing naturally
to fight their cancer this is the
starting point and we're course very
interested in this why do some patients
have a strong immune response like the
one on the right and other patients the
immune response is much weaker this is
important for a number of reasons but
the main one is shown toward the bottom
of the figure here which is if we look
at survival rates patients and and we
just score them according to the
strength of their in the in response you
can see that with these water immune
responses on average patients have like
about a two-fold better chance of
surviving and with the astronomy
responses that's about a three-fold
better chance this is I should clarify
if I'm giving you information just know
Varian cancer those what the numbers
look like at the same pattern the same
thing applies to virtually every other
type of solid
cancer where the presence of a strong
immune response is a good thing it leads
to survival so we've known this for
about 10 or 20 years now and this has
really provided inspiration for thinking
about okay well what can we do to
enhance these immune responses how do we
make a strong immune response even
stronger and how do we get an immune
response started in somebody where it's
a weak immune response to begin with so
with the neo therapy that's all we're
trying to do is really understand these
responses and learn ways to amplify them
so that those survival rates can go up
even higher
so what's holding back union response
you know if you've got a strong immune
response why do you have cancer at all
well it turns out like any biological
system there are negative feedback loops
in the system and so the immune response
is no different
there are both stimulatory and
inhibitory signals that these immune
cells are being guided by and a really
important set of signals has shown in
this illustration here so I'm showing a
tumor cell on the upper cell and then a
t-cell in the lower cell and my pointer
back here one important signal is the
antigen triggering activation of the
t-cell receptor that turns the t-cell on
and gets it activated those that signal
is opposed by negative signals in a
particularly important pathway not the
only one but a very important one is
called the PD one PDL one pathway which
actually sends a negative signal to the
cells so to illustrate this we can think
of the gas pedal and the brakes on your
car the antigen and t-cell receptor
interaction is like putting your foot on
the gas that activates the T cell if any
one PDL one interaction is the brake
it's like putting your foot on the brake
and basically slows down our impedes the
T cell response and this is what this
brake looks like in the real world so
back to ovarian cancer which I'm using
as our example today we're looking at a
tumor now and this time we've stained it
for two different things we've got our T
cells the good guys are in green so you
can see those green cells by the way
these colors keep chained
just because we use different scanning
methods to to reveal these cells the
cells themselves are white white blood
cells as I said earlier but here they're
looking green the way we've stained them
and then in brown we're staining for
this PDL one molecule which is part of
the breaking mechanism I just mentioned
and we see these PDL one positive cells
which we know by other means are cell
type called macrophages macrophages are
normally good guys they are kind of like
the garbage man that go pick up the
garbage throughout the body dead cell
debris etc but in this case the
macrophages due to the biology here are
starting to express this PDL one which
is providing a break that's actually
slowing down or stalling out those good
guys the cd8 positive T cells and you
can see that almost everywhere that we
see T cell in green it's surrounded by a
cloud of these PDL 1 positive
macrophages obviously making it very
difficult for those T cells to do their
job and actually attack a tumor so it's
a bit like being in a car with the
driver from hell if you will who have
their foot on the gas and on the brake
at the same time and you're sort of just
lurching forward in traffic but really
not getting anywhere productively so you
could think of that as a stalemate so
with the needle therapy then we seek to
enhance these responses we want to take
the foot off the brake and click more on
the gas we want to break through
stalemates etc and this is the figure I
showed you before just as a reminder
that there's lots of different ways to
think about doing that and I'll start
working through those a few of those
examples now and show you some of the
successes so
first is just really building on what
I've said just a minute ago with this
gas and brake analogy is to take the
foot off the brake and the way that's
done pharmacologically these days is
various groups to come up with
antibodies illustrating here that an
antibody to PD one for example or in
yellow an antibody to PDL one which can
come in there and basically block that
interaction between p1 and PDL one and
disengage that brake so you now have a
scenario where in this case you've
gotten foot on the gas still there's our
gas pedal
but you disengaged the brake and so the
t cell you know is activated it's free
to go and attack that tumor cell and
kill it I'll just point out that um in
practice you use it you don't need both
of these antibodies you wouldn't need to
block both pd-1 and PDL one at the same
time but rather these are two different
drugs that hit the same pathway so this
approach is called checkpoint blockade
the others reasons we think of these
brakes others refer to them as in the
analogical checkpoint so with checkpoint
blockade
we're walking those checkpoints and here
are some of the clinical successes that
have been reported around the world just
in the last five years or so and I'm not
here to promote any particular drug name
that these are just some of the common
drugs that are out there that patients
are carrying the boat and knowing about
so I've turned some of those names up
there but in no way intending to promote
one over the other um I talked about the
PD one break one I didn't mention but
you could see at the top there is a
another grating mechanism involves a
molecule called ctla-4 and that was
actually that drugs against that target
were first out of the gate and received
FDA approval for melanoma
a few years ago now as far as blocking
the pd-1 pathway there's a number of
drugs out there that can do that and you
can just look down this list and see the
wide variety of cancers that are
responding to this as a type of
treatment and I've highlighted in blue
the FDA approvals that we've seen just
really in the last few years so this is
why we're talking about this being a
revolution in cancer treatment this is a
lot of FDA approvals across a wide
variety of cancers in a really short
period of time and it's really just
become a game changer for oncology a
couple of things I'll I'll highlight for
example with Hodgkin's lymphoma
with this approach is about an 87
percent objective response rate which is
just absolutely remarkable recently had
an FDA approval for one of these agents
one of these drugs for treating any
adult or pediatric metastatic solid
tumor that has a particular type of DNA
repair issue called mismatch repair
deficiency so this is a very sweeping
approval that cuts across all types of
cancer that have this genetic aberration
in them and that's really an
unprecedented type of FDA approval and
then at the bottom here I'll just point
out that these agents are now starting
to replace front-line chemotherapy for
melanoma and lung cancer and in all
likelihood other cancers and many other
cancers will follow suit so this is the
revolution that I'm talking about where
we'll actually see chemotherapy being
replaced now by immunotherapy and for
those of us that have worked in the you
know therapy field for several decades
such as myself I think we are asking
ourselves could we ever really expect to
see this in our lifetime I mean this is
just really fantastic progress that
we're we're very excited
so of course everything brings
challenges so what are what what are so
that challenges with checkpoint blockade
cost these new drugs are coming in at
about a hundred thousand dollars per
treatment cycle just using graph numbers
but they're considered expensive drugs
for some cancers combinations of these
drugs may be required so two drugs
capilla needle are now recommended for
use together to treat melanoma in some
cases so that doubles the cost as well
as any side effects when they come along
and then for for these drugs that big
question is how long do you need to keep
a patient on them if they're responding
do they need to stay on the driver can
you stop giving the drug you might think
well if you should activate the immune
system maybe it can do the rest of the
job on its own and the drums are no
longer required or you might think well
though if you are getting your foot off
the brake you got to keep it off the
brake for as long as possible so this is
the big issue is how long do the patient
need to stay on these agents and and
length the time of course adds to cost
and side-effects the other big issue is
under efficacy or how well they work so
many cancers I've given you some of the
best examples but there's other cancers
such as ovarian ovarian and breast where
the response rates are still
disappointingly low down in the 10%
range or so and also the responses are
often transient and with lung cancer
there's a lot of success here but for
most patients there it doesn't appear
that yet that they're being churned by
these drugs they're getting a lot of
benefit but it may not be forever so
there's a lot of work still could be
done then on these issues
and this slide shows just really how
complex the interactions are between the
immune system and cancer but also all
the other opportunities that lie ahead
for us so this is looking at all the gas
pedals and brakes most of them that we
know about that make up the dialogue
between t-cells and their target cells
so I've talked about pd-1 PDL one
pathway and there is up near the top of
the list I've also mentioned the ctla-4
pathway there it is but you can see
there are a lot of other molecules
involved in this dialogue and in this
context it's really actually quite
remarkable that just taking disrupting
one of these braking mechanisms has any
influence I've just shown you how
effective these two pathways can be when
targeted quite remarkable when you put
in the context of all the other
signaling pathways that need to be
considered so the field right now is
very excited and working through some of
these other gas pedals and brakes and
learning developing drugs against them
and learning how to use these in
combination and really learn how to
drive these t-cells as effectively as
possible so t-cells and you know an
analogy I use you know they're not like
an old biplane not like the first
airplanes that first came out that just
had very simple steering wheels and etc
but they're more like a 747 with a very
complex dashboard and that's good
because that allows our immune systems
to do very sophisticated things but it
also means that some work is going to be
required to really learn how to drive
them
so this is another view of this what we
call the synapse or the the space the
communications channel between here now
the t-cell is on the bottom and the
target cell is on the top and just
showing some of these molecules again
and then in purple indicating where some
of these checkpoint blockade antibodies
operate so that's what we've already
talked about I'm showing this now to
just kind of point out how these are
working inside the t-cell so all of
these molecule down below are the
intracellular circuitry that t-cells use
to interpret the signals coming through
these gas pedals and brakes so these are
you know part of the brains of the
t-cell if you will to take all this
information collect it all and then
ultimately make decisions for the t-cell
about okay are we going to attack this
tumor cell or not so all that
information gets integrated into some
very complex intracellular signaling
machinery and and there's opportunities
there as well than for therapies where
one can think about coming in with drugs
that modulate these signaling pathways
is another approach to to changing the
behavior of the t-cells and I'll show
you an example of that later but how do
we do this in a really rational way and
when we think about the future if the
future going to be giving patients all
sorts of different antibodies as we're
currently doing that affect these
signaling pathways or can we be thinking
about genetically engineering the
t-cells changing these intracellular
signaling circuits so that the t-cell
actually starts behaving differently and
I'm a proponent of the latter approach I
think the future of the neo therapy for
cancer is going to involve actually
getting in there and genetically
engineering the t-cells
to change their response characteristics
and I'll I'll say more about that and
and also make the case that it's it's
doable it's yielding some early
successes and there's huge opportunities
so I back to our wheel here what I'm
going to talk about now is something
called adoptive cell transfer up in that
quadrant and this is where the
opportunities lie from doing these types
of genetic engineering approaches so
I'll introduce the topic of adopted T
cell therapy often called a CT for short
and this is really a variety of
approaches but they all follow the same
basic concept here but there's lots of
flavors but basically it starts by
collecting T cells from a patient from
either their tumor or a blood sample you
can then identify or as we'll talk about
genetically engineered cells to
recognize the tumor you then expand the
T cells typically in the lab to
reasonable and large numbers and then
those T cells can be infused back into
the patient's bloodstream just through a
simple IV bag and often we would give
drugs along with them to help help them
out such as the checkpoint drugs we've
talked about but those T cells what's
there back in the bloodstream can
circulate throughout the patient's
entire body and they can be then able to
recognize and respond to destroy the
cancer cells wherever they might lie so
this is a great opportunity to really
take control of the immune system change
its properties and create just
supercharged T cell response and just to
show you
powerful this can be this is data that
my group published a number of years ago
now just in a mouse model breast cancer
where we did t-cell therapy just with
some pretty simple maneuver we just
basically increased the number of tumor
reactive t-cells and they know so we
didn't genetically engineer them or
anything fancy like that but just by
increasing the number of t-cell to
supercharge levels you can see the tumor
on the left is an untreated tumor this
would be like some of the human tumors I
showed you where there's really not much
as in the in response going on and then
panel B shows what a similar tumor would
look like seven days after giving
adoptive t-cell therapy and all of those
little brown cells you see in their
hundreds or thousands of them each one
of them that the t-cell you can see that
has just very strongly profoundly
invaded the tumor tissue in fact what we
see in these mice models is that the two
have actually swell up for a few days
after t-cell therapy because they become
so charcoal and T cells
she sells really cool her take it and
then the tumor collapses over the next
few days and by about ten to fourteen
days later in these most models the
tumors actually completely disappear
just eradicated by the T cells alone and
never come back you know that's in most
models I'm not claiming simple as that
in in people yet but this really shows
us the potential and the power of this
approach so doctor T cell therapy has
been evaluated in clinical trials with
real patients for a number of years now
there's some two different types that
I'll talk about and two that have really
had the most experience so far the first
is called kill therapy and that uses
tool infiltrating lymphocytes it's a
relatively simple procedure in that
there's no genetic engineering involved
one just takes the T cells that are
naturally found in the tumor and I
showed you examples of those earlier you
can just harvest those T cells activate
them in the lab getting the right growth
factors and grow them up to very large
numbers and get them back to the patient
through their through an IV infusion and
that's just a way of really greatly
increasing the numbers and activation
state of the cells and you can see that
that achieves a very impressive response
rates in advanced melanoma and there's
also been some positive results reported
in the cervical cancer other cancers are
currently under clinical trials and the
results so far are not as impressive in
other cancers as it has originally seen
in melanoma so that's a real area of
research to figure out how to how to
raise those response rates but
nonetheless that gives you an idea of
when a very common therapy that's being
tested today and then the second example
are and I'll say more about it I'll just
briefly mention it now and give you
details later but is using something
called car T cells in a particular car T
cells that have been engineered to
recognize B cells marker call cd19 which
have just had phenomenal success against
certain types of leukemia and lymphoma
and very recently received FDA approval
in that setting so we'll talk about car
chief cells in just a few minutes
in order to do t-cell therapy you need
specialized infrastructure these days
and so at our Center in in British
Columbia we've just built a facility for
clinical grade t-cell production so that
we can make these products and safely
treat our patients
I'll just at this point mention you know
there is infrastructure is required and
and so this is can be seen as a costly
treatment I think the way we do it today
is fairly costly but there are ways to
bring those costs down in the future and
to really simplify the manufacturing
processes going forward so it's a bit
like the computers when in the 1970s
computer filled up an entire room and
now the same capabilities are easily
reduced down to an iPhone I think
similar games can be made with T cell
therapy once we figure out how to do it
we'll be able to simplify it but this is
kind of where we're at today so just to
give you an idea this is a trial that
we're planning at our Center to treat
relapsed gynecologic cancers so that's a
variant cervical and individual cancer
just to give you an idea how this fits
into the rest of the patients treatment
I'm showing you an example an ovarian
cancer patient this is a data from a
real patient although she didn't receive
t-cell therapy but I'm gonna show you
how we could have tried to help her with
t-cell therapy instead she received um
chemotherapy as indicated here which is
standard of care and you can see that
that gave a good response she actually
went into remission this is just a graph
her tumor burden over time but she then
had a relapse as you can see the tumor
came back had additional rounds of
chemotherapy which unfortunately she did
achieve another remission but you can
see it was very short-lived this is the
years after diagnosis so just a few
months and then sadly the cancer came
back a second time
and she was given further treatment but
that was not successful and sadly she
died in her disease so this is the
current kind of roller coaster that
ovarian cancer patients go on today with
with our current treatments and what our
clinical trial will do as indicated here
would be the patient would still have
their primary chemo therapy as shown
here because that is effective for most
patients and they do achieve remission
in a trial when the patient has relapses
at that point we would collect a tumor
sample from the relapse tumor and we
would harvest the T cells from it and
we'd get busy growing those T cells in
the lab well the patient went on and had
their second line chemotherapy which we
hope will help them and we hope they
never need their T cells but
unfortunately we know that most will
most will if they relapsed once they're
a very high risk of relapse and again
but when that second relapse happens we
would then be able to come in with our T
cell therapy which involves us I won't
get the details but there's a lymph node
completion step then the T cells are
infused and they gave us back to call
dial 2 to help support those T cells and
our goal would be to learn off I fight
off that relapsed tumor so this is what
a clinical trial would look like
eventually once we get this really
working figure out how to use it
we of course like to move it more to a
frontline so perhaps trying to treat
them very first recurrence or possibly
than combining it into the upfront care
to prevent relapses from happening in
the first place so with clinical trials
we always start for various reasons as
we always start with sort of later stage
disease but once something starts to
work we move it earlier into the
treatment course
what can we do to improve on this it's
in some ways you can think of it as a
platform once your t-cell therapy going
you don't have opportunities to come in
and and make it better
so there's ways that we can optimize the
t-cells by making them getting better
selecting out the tumour reactive
t-cells very precisely we can also
genetically engineer the t-cells to make
them more potent and I'll show you how
we could do that and you can think about
optimizing their tumor as well softening
it up so that it's more receptive to a
t-cell attack so there's drugs that can
do that and I'll show you a briefly an
example you can use viruses on Kalitta
viruses an occult is another way to in
that case infect the tumor with the
virus and causing an immune response
that then these transferred t-cells have
better access to the tumor and a better
opportunity to kill it it's all sorts of
them I think really exciting ideas for
how to improve on till therapy this is
an example of how genetic engineering
could help with this kind of approach so
this is a study that we published a
number of years ago but really
illustrate the point so here I'm just
showing a cartoon of all those signaling
pathways we talked about earlier the gas
pedals and in brakes that control it he
saw well there are internal breaks as
well so there's a protein called Sybil
be indicated here in red which serve as
a as a braking mechanism within the cell
and basically puts the brake on a number
of these signaling pathways and and
symbol B is there to protect us it it
helps prevent autoimmunity so that's
important but here's an opportunity
where we can delete remove that Sybil B
gene just in the t-cells that are
attacking the tumor so when we do our
adopted T cell therapy and we have the T
cell out of the patient
body in the lab we can then engineer
them to remove this civil B gene and
when that was done this has been a most
model of breast cancer we did the
adoptive t cell therapy with what we
call wild-type T cells are just the
unmodified natural T cells they don't do
a very good job of getting into the
tumor and when we look at tumor growth
over time these tumors just keep getting
bigger and bigger the T cells had no
beneficial effect whatsoever but just by
deleting or knocking out this Sybil B
gene from the T cells you can see the T
cells know are much better able to get
into the tumor so we get very strong
infiltration and you can see the
response here that these T cells
eventually cause complete regression
complete disappearance of those tumors
from the mice so just by changing one
part of the circuitry inside the T so
we've gone from an ineffective immune
response to a cure so that's the
potential of genetic engineering and
quite we and others are excited about it
I'll talk about chimeric antigen
receptors or cars I mentioned them
earlier and said that gives you more
details this is a really a phenomenal
area it involves genetic engineering and
it's a great example of where we are
today and what the future holds so cars
they're called chimeric because they
have them they're made up of two parts
they have an antibody like region that
is able to bind to recognize the tumor
and then they have the signaling
components of a t-cell receptor so a gas
pedal on the inside so these molecules
are put engineered into a t cell so the
t cell marrow on its surface has the
antibody like portion and if that
antibody recognizes a tumor cell it
basically is like putting the foot on
the gas
the t-cell becomes activated and will
attack the tumor cell so the antibodies
can be engineered to be against any
protein but where the biggest success so
far has come is from a protein called
cd19
which is expressed on certain leukemias
so we call these cd19 cars the redirect
t-cells to recognize these b-cell
leukemias and as I mentioned before
phenomenal successes 90% complete
response rates with about 2/3 of those
being durable responses in both kids and
adults with leukemia and leading to very
recently to FDA approval for some
indications and then also very
impressive responses in lymphoma but
also some room for improvement there as
we can see so this is another revolution
in cancer the idea that we're now
treating patients with genetically
engineered T cells
who would have guessed even 10 years ago
that we we'd get here so quickly so in
Canada I'll just mention what we're
doing in our in in our research area
we're actually forming a national car T
cell network funded through an
organization called PI on Canada Rex
where we're working our groups in
Victoria in Vancouver are working with
there have been a lot of walk to produce
cartoon cells so we're taking care of
the viral manufacturing as well as the T
cell manufacturing and opening clinical
trials up at other sites and eventually
inviting other cities in Canada to
participate in this network not just
Canada but internationally as well so
we're expanding this to international
collaborations and the reason we're
doing this is because we see so much
opportunity here and we think keeping
this in the public sector are having it
the public sector will be important to
keep the cost under control and also to
allow as much innovation as possible
I'll talk next about how ideas for
improving your own currency sells it's
going to take a lot of work and these
cars with our current models but it's
going to be just like cars in the real
world each year there's going to be new
models coming up in the showroom with
better and better features and so we
want to be set up to be able to
contribute to that progress so how can
you make a better car well 90% complete
response rate is pretty good isn't it
but there is room for improvement and
also we want to be able to build cars
they don't act other types of cancers
beside leukemias and lymphomas so what
are the downsides with cars though
they're shown here at the bottom couple
are related to side effects something
called cytokine release syndrome which
can cause serious problems for patients
although physicians are getting better
at managing it there are also euro
toxicities with unclear etiology or
cause which have led to some fatalities
obviously very serious patients also
lose their healthy b-cells those are the
important immune cells for as long as
the car t-cells are present and as I
indicated before about a third of
patients relapse so they have a good
response but the tumor comes back and
often it has lost the target that the
cars recognize these involve exceeding
its 19 negative tumors so these are some
of the issues that need to be solved
just in the setting of leukemias and
lymphomas not shown here though is you
know how do we also expand current
t-cells to treat other cancers like lung
cancer breast cancer and so on so one
idea that we're developing in
collaboration that dr. Marty Boulanger
at the University of Victoria
something we call mate where we
essentially take the car and we break it
into two parts again we separate the
antibody component up top here from the
receptor component shown down here the
signaling component and then we stick
them together again with if you will
with a Velcro like attachment so that
they will come together and stick
together but they're not hardwired
together and what this somewhat simple
change allows is that you can then give
the patient the car T cells expressing
just the receptor but those that
receptor will not be activated unless
the physician actually gives the patient
antibody as an infusion
so the antibody kippur portion becomes
like a drug that you can give the
patient when you want to activate the
car T cells but if there's any serious
side effects you can stop giving you
anybody and that will cool off the whole
reaction or if the patient is cured of
their leukemia let's say and you don't
need the car T cells anymore just stop
giving anybody all together and those
colored T cells will no longer be
activated so a simple idea but it then
gives a very much better control over
the whole reaction so I just put that up
there as one idea for how to make our T
cells better so just I think ad this one
at a very brief example not going to go
through all of these but just I wanted
to give a concept of the diversity of
ideas out there and so I'll just end by
talking about Uncle edik viruses which
is a think a real up-and-coming part of
the immunotherapy landscape it has also
achieved some success recently so poetic
viruses are viruses that are either
selected or engineered to
recognize and attack chillers so oka
lytic meaning cancer busting so this top
panel shows what happens when a healthy
cell is infected by a virus
see the green virus going in there but
in a healthy cell divided these are
clinic viruses are are such that the
they do they're not successful inside
health it so they can infect them
perhaps but they're not able to
replicate inside them due to differences
in their signaling properties but the
viruses are selected such that when they
find themselves inside a cancer cell
shown here is the purple cell that
that's just the perfect environment for
them to replicate they've got all the
right signals and other factors that
they need so they replicate like crazy
and eventually killed that cancer cell
and releasing all those viral particles
which can then go and do the same thing
to the next cancer cell along so that's
the you know basic idea of the angle
including viruses and what everybody
hopes that they will do what's been
learned from working with them if they
do something else in addition which is
that they stimulated an immune response
against the tumor the insistent looks at
this and says wait there's some sort of
viral infection going on over here and
the T cells and B cells come rushing in
to fight the virus and in so doing they
then notice the tumor can start
attacking it as well and so one type of
alkaloid virus it's known as T back I
will try and say the full name here
indicated up here this was just received
FDA approval for the treatment of
melanoma and with T back what was done
as they they wanted to really enhance
this immune stimulatory effect so they
introduced a gene for a molecule called
gm-csf which we will get into the
details here but it actually helps
really promote stronger t-cell response
and so you get not only the direct
killing of
by the virus but you stimulate the
immune system and that's important
because what it means is that you can
perhaps inject the virus into one tumor
in the patient but by triggering an
immune response those t-cells can then
go and kill off tumor deposits elsewhere
in the body that the virus might not be
able to to get to on its own so you go
from a local effect to a systemic effect
so here's some picture of what these on
clinic viruses can do just this is work
from my lab just to make a simple point
how they can trigger an immune response
so this is an untreated tumor on the
left again there's no t-cells in these
tumors at baseline in this particular
model then after infecting this tumor
with an oncolytic virus called VSD
looking a few days later you can see
that the t-cells have come rushing in
those all those brown cells and they are
not fighting the virus no doubt but also
attacking the tumor and in our most
models we can actually get complete
regression of these tumors by infecting
them with these oncolytic viruses so in
closing the cur treatments for cancer
the village every one surgery radiation
therapy chemotherapy hormone therapy
some of the newer drugs are often
referred to as targeted therapies but
what we have here now adding to this is
the needle therapy this slide is to say
coming soon it now says new and it's
actually here as I've shown and with all
these FDA approvals lots of potential
from the future as well that is
replacing chemotherapy in some settings
might replace some of these other
therapies but it's not a competition
here it's really about finding the right
combination for each
type of cancer I think all of these
other treatments will still have their
place in the future but in ela therapy
will certainly be a big part of things
so it's really an unprecedented
opportunity we're seeing long-lasting
curative treatments not curing everybody
far from it but but some really good
signals lower side effects overall wide
applicability natural mechanism of
action so what working with the body's
own immune system and it also leads to
opportunities for locally produced
t-cell therapies as we talked about
which creates jobs talent innovation
intellectual property can help the cost
control so from socio-economic side of
things as well the other therapy
especially in these adoptive t-cell
therapy offers these additional benefits
so I'll just show these are the many
people in my lab and various
collaborators who I've worked with over
the years haven't covered everybody's
work here far from it but just want to
acknowledge a large team that I'm
fortunate to work with both scientists
and clinicians across Canada and around
the world and we have our various
funding organizations as well but most
of all I want to thank our patients who
contributed so generously tumor samples
and blood samples from our studies and
all the patients around the world who
are participating in these clinical
trials of immunotherapy and have allowed
these breakthroughs to really happen and
show the world the potential of this new
approach to cancer treatment and I'll
close there and open this up for
discussion thanks very much for your
attention thank you dr. Nelson for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the bottom
we're at the lower left of the
presentation window type your answer
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many questions as we have time for
okay
batching all set our first question of
the day asks what kind of side effects
are associated with immunotherapy that's
an excellent question
yeah I can't it that there were some and
with car t-cells are talked about some
of the serious ones including this
neurotoxic would be leading to death
that's as serious as it gets and are
better concern let me back up though and
just talk about let's start with these
checkpoint therapies the first thing I
talked about these drugs that affect the
brakes on the immune system always
generally have for some patients there's
no side effects and for others there's
some inflammation that's caused
autoimmune like syndromes can be caused
all of those are transient in the vast
majority of patients and so patient
might experience these while they're on
treatment that they they resolved with
time so fortunately we're not seeing
immunotherapies causing long-term
autoimmunity in patients but nonetheless
well on treatment some patients might
experience things like colitis
inflammation of the bowel for example
and not to minimize that experience for
the patient but um it's a it is
temporary and they could move on and
more or less get back to normal after
that with the car T cells we the
toxicities can be more significant but
clinicians are learning quickly how to
manage these and for that bad outcomes
and I talked I gave examples of how we
think with better engineering we can
gain better control of these reactions
and minimize things much further so
overall the toxicities are are
manageable and certainly no worse than
you see with other cancer treatments
okay thank you for that information
the second question today asks what are
the costs associated with immunotherapy
yeah so I touched on that but I'm
thankful for the question just say a bit
more about it in general these
checkpoint anybody's or ballpark figures
are about a hundred thousand dollars per
patient that's not out of line with
other modern cancer treatments so it's
not like sounded like a lot to some
people but it's not considered crazy
money in you know in ecology but its
sustainability for our healthcare
systems is a big issue the more
successful these agents are the more
patients will receive them and that
creates costs for the healthcare system
and whether it's a private or public
health care system somebody has to
figure out how to pay those bills so it
was talking about combining these
different immunotherapies those costs
could really stack out and I think it's
fair to say every health care system is
concerned about this and how to pay for
it my view is like anything things
usually start out expensive and then
they get less expensive with time as we
figure out how to use them better how to
innovate further things come off patents
eventually that will bring down costs
allow market for generics and I think
with T cell engineering I've tried to
make the case we could by by just
changing the circuitry at T cells you
might be able to eliminate or reduce the
need for some of these other expensive
drugs to get at the same time thank you
for your answer let's see the third
question of the day asks will
immunotherapy eventually work for all
types of cancer great question the
so I showed quite a diversity of cancers
that are responding to checkpoint
blockade for example the cancers that
are responding today to today's drugs in
general one thing they all have in
common is they have a very high mutation
load as we say by that I mean they have
a lot of mutations in them at the very
beginning we talked about how cancers
acquire mutations and I showed you some
of those chromosome pictures and how
messed up the cancer genome becomes
somewhat ironically the more messed up
the cancer is the debtor it responds to
chemotherapy and the reason for that we
think is because the more an f-stop of
cancer is the more foreign it looks to
the immune system and the more willing
the immune system is to attack it more
able it is to attack it so other cancers
so such as ovarian cancer which I talked
a lot about in general don't have that
many mutations overall and so they're
not responding as well to today's
immunity repeats so what about the
future
I think there's lots of potential using
for example car T cells to the tumor
doesn't look messed up enough we can
still teach the T cells or engineer them
to recognize other features on the tumor
other than mutations that would allow
for a good immune response so in theory
there's no reason to think immunotherapy
couldn't be beneficial for every type of
cancer a time will tell which cancers
proved to be the most sensitive thank
you looks like we have time for one more
question say dr. Nelson in this question
at what can I do to strengthen my immune
system this is a question I get a lot
from patients when they hear my
presentation they say well O'Sullivan
say
had cancer 20 years ago and I'm still
alive and I've taken this particular
extract all these years all right down
yoga or this with Adam I'm pretty sure
that's why I beat my cancer and who keep
people who have survived and have those
beliefs I say good on you it's not for
me to say otherwise because I think the
patient's know inside themselves what's
working for them so I'm just a scientist
that tries to make things better but if
you're alive then there's nothing like
it can do much better than that so so so
patients know to some extent but then
some also want to know are there some is
there practical advice I could give and
in general there's not a lot of
scientific evidence for all the steel
ating nutriceuticals and things that are
out there the various projects you'd
find in a health food store many of them
claim to boost the immune response for
very few of them if any have really hard
scientific evidence for that again that
doesn't mean they don't work or don't
help some people I don't mean to be
dismissive of it but I'm a scientist and
scientists we like to answer questions
by doing experiments and you know let's
give a thousand people this agent and a
thousand people of placebo and see what
happens so for most of these
nutriceuticals those kind of many
rigorous scientific studies haven't been
done so if you're wanting to have an a
science-based approach to life
that wouldn't goes would he offer
solutions on the other hand it again if
anyone's taking them and think the
benefit from them then don't let me tell
you otherwise
but what do I do in my own life I think
your immune system we all have a bit of
a barometer for it which is we all know
when we're feeling tired and rundown and
we're more likely to get check out that
cold virus or something we all go
through those phases or feelings
those are that's your barometer telling
you your immune system probably yes on a
low gear and not firing optimally so
what do you do to get out of those you
know kind of states get a good night's
sleep eat healthy food get some exercise
lower your stress get back to feeling
really good and strong just as a as a
person and that's when your immune
system is really doing the best so in
order to take it to a supercharged level
I think it's hard to do that with
lifestyle and everything I talked about
today with amigo therapy and I think
that's where science can really come in
and and help supercharge things
otherwise it's really just about
following you know good advice about
healthy living well thank you so much
dr. Nelson for your presentation and I
would also like to thank you for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through January of
2018 you will receive an email for
labrum Robert letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again here soon at Lavery's goodbye